wirklich wahr die parteien der
niederlande lassen traditionell von
einer neutralen stelle ausrechnen was
die erfüllung ihrer wahlversprechen
kosten würde
wir tragen sie doch aus spaß mal wer da
nicht mitmacht richtig die blonde claude
st wie realistisch ist das programm von
gerd dazu jetzt eine neue folge von und
gerd ruge hat ja ich verstehe ich nicht
wieso an holland eigentlich jeden
milliarden euro mehr wenn wir alle
muslime rausschmeißen das eine gute
frage und den koran zu verbieten
müsstest du das grundgesetz ändern will
das er geht mit einem mickrigen foods
inc
das kann ich dir gerne erklären ich aber
erst das kiffen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wäre nie
[Musik]
[Applaus]